as a reporter who covers the french
government in paris i often get asked if
france is veering right
macron is likely to be re-elected in
april but marine le pen the nationalist
leader whom he faced in the runoff in
the previous selection is still there
she's quite resilient she's also joined
by another far-right candidate former tv
pundit former journalist eric zemo
on the one hand for sure it certainly
looks this way the far right is pulling
around thirty percent for the april
presidential election um you add the
conservative candidate it's about forty
percent versus what twenty five thirty
percent for the left and a lot of the
most controversial views of the far
right on religion especially islam
on migrants foreigners they're not being
shared openly people are more
comfortable with them and i can tell you
that firsthand i have been to rallies of
this tv pandit new far-right hero
eriksen
and yes the people are not ashamed of
their views at all
some of the values that are
traditionally assigned to the left such
as feminism fighting climate change also
tolerance for other religions or
tolerance from migrants that is
progressing in french society which
means well french society is supposed to
be veering left but you cannot see that
in polls why there are a lot of factors
to explain this one of them is that
friends is a society that's aging and
older people tend to vote more than
younger people and also they tend to be
more conservative
what we may be witnessing though is the
increasing polarization of the french
political landscape since macron in 2017
with his neither left nor right run
effectively diana mighted the
traditional left wing and right-wing
parties and a lot of what's left is now
on the fringes of course the core
question is what has a load micro in the
first place to come in and to destroy
the traditional left wing and the right
wing parties and borrow from both of
them well there are a lot of
explanations again but some of them are
the disappointment we're fooling parties
from the left and from the right and
also the fact that a lot of right-wing
people have adopted what used to be
left-wing or progressive or liberal
ideas such as gay marriage and in the
meantime a lot of left-wing people have
adopted what used to be right-wing
ideas and finally one should not
underestimate the impact and the role of
u.s politics whether it's the typography
the graphics the the hats sayings they
move 2022 which really look like maga
hats or you know the fact that zimbabwe
mentioned at some point
they are preparing to steal the election
from you that sounds very familiar
[Music]